your husband needs a [ __ ] compromise
dude yeah be more romantic be more
present during the day during the
non-sex time
hello
hey matt hey chris huge fan of the
podcast you guys literally keep me sane
while i'm at work so thank you chris my
baby for life so is my husband
um my question for you guys is about
relationships slash marriage
sex
um my husband and i have been together
for almost nine years got married young
had kids young in back to back so
our kids are three and a half and two
and a half we're slowly seeing some more
independence and freedom come back that
we used to have
but the number one thing that has
changed is
our sex life so
straight up my husband
would like to have sex every single day
and for me that's just not realistic
so
i guess my question to you is how do i
meet him in the middle how much is too
much how little is too little
you know we're trying to figure this out
and obviously i want to keep him happy
at the same time so it's just been the
number one thing that we are bumping
heads really we have completely
different views on it wow so any advice
would be great
wow that's the number one thing huh
first of all
everything it all sounds real normal
sometimes it's the woman who wants more
sex sometimes it's the man everything's
normal once a day
is
not i wouldn't call it abnormal but that
is absolutely not compromising
yeah true it's like the guy needs to
your husband needs a [ __ ] competition
so i want to be on the dude's team
because you know
but it's just i can't i want someone i
got to be a horrible person here seven
times a week yeah 365 times a year come
on
it needs to be more i think it should be
three four times a day no i um you need
to do it a thousand five hundred times a
year let's talk about once a week let's
start there well
start there i said what do you mean
start there once a week or her her start
well they're coming out once a week
together it's like [ __ ] sex shark
tanks he has sex five times a week she
has sex twice a week they're a couple
they all have sex the same amount of
time yeah no no but i'm saying for her
to be like i'll give you once a week
that's what you're saying sure you've
got to come to the table a little bit on
the [ __ ] but my question for her is
how much does she want to have sex she
left it out yeah i bet she's like i just
i'm not you know i bet that that's the
deal so she's got to meet him a little
bit that's what i'm saying and also but
here's the other thing dude if you're
anything like me dude if the guy's
anything like me i don't want to have
sex with somebody that doesn't want to
that's what i that's what i never
understood about [ __ ] this kind of
[ __ ] it's like you know
you hear stories like this and it's just
like but but here's the thing i get it
if he's like
but but it's not it's he wants to have
sex once a [ __ ] day but but it's
different but when it's like what
happened to our passion
like that let i need to you to try to
rediscover that that's much much more
valid but to be like i don't care that
you don't want to have sex with me i
want it once a day that's like
that's like [ __ ] nice we don't know
what is what he's saying but she said it
what do you mean no no she's saying if
it were up to my husband he would like
to have it once a day it's not
necessarily like he's henry the eighth i
watch the tutors and when they [ __ ]
he would be like this is what we're
doing and you have to abide by that okay
but um
yeah dude i don't know i mean also
there's other thing
foreplay is every tell this guy this
foreplay is everything you do before sex
not just in the bedroom it's everything
you said that before it's buying flowers
it's doing other things it's it's
setting your uh alarm for when you wake
up it's well no but turning on the hot
part uh the hot faucet so it's the water
is lukewarm when it comes out of the
sink it's not necessarily that i'm just
saying it could be everything you do up
until you have sex in may you got to
make your partner the focus of
more
i bet too
more who's this for is it for her no for
him i'm saying i bet
i bet
there's a thing here where if he were to
focus on you more not just sexually but
in a romantic way
you would um
want to have sex a little bit more i
think maybe not and if not then it's
something else but i don't know if um
so you're saying
the problem is the sex the problem might
be the connection but it's it's say
going with that would you say that
she should suggest to him
more foreplay and she might be more
likely to want to do it yeah be more
romantic be more present during the day
during the non-sex times you're saying
she should tell him yeah uh i think you
should just
tell him
start i think you should start with once
a day is unrealistic
because we're married and have been
married for a long time and we're not
19. it is uh and so
what let's come up with some kind of
compromise
whether that is once every
if once a week is outrageous
i mean it's okay so maybe if he does
that maybe once then what would you like
maybe once between monday and friday and
then once on the weekend like that might
be fine for him but again i i also come
back to the thing chris said which is
like
why is this
guy trying to [ __ ]
when you don't wanna i get he would like
you to want to right and again talking
to her about rekindling some kind of
flame starting foreplay doing things
that make her happy to make her sort of
more excited about having sex but like
to just be like we're [ __ ] today and
we're [ __ ] tomorrow we're [ __ ]
every day and that's what we have to do
to satisfy me i mean of course you don't
want to
who the [ __ ] that's what i'm saying yeah
that's not a connection yeah but there's
others so you're val you not only have a
valid point to say that's too much you
have a valid point to be like well why
would i want to
yeah like this is not like some exciting
new relationship like do something more
modern don't treat me like i'm just a
fried butterfly right like what is that
think about what a fried butterfly i did
think about it pink
why do you well now it's pink think
about a fried butterfly if it were pink
now what this sounds like i need more
things what does it look like if there's
fried butterfly foods if there was a
slit in the middle of it
[Music]
you're just talking about describing age
restricted you're gonna you're just
describing a female genitalia there we
go okay i could have said that if i want
to be you know well that would have been
way more clinical i'm just saying
that is a stupid-ass way to say well you
would try butterfly with a slit in it
okay wow don't just treat me like so
inelegant you know
he's just like wait what uh what
what about a fried
okay
a a pink fried butterfly with a slit in
it that you dropped in water
and took it out and it's
and now it looks like that
the worst writer the [ __ ] worst
spitballing a poet spitballing poet do
you understand if i read a book with and
it said all that it'd be my favorite
book dude so [ __ ] off man that would be
so the best [ __ ] oh i gotta write that
up really
but he um yeah just yeah be open and
talk you know guys struggle talking
about this [ __ ] too so uh but he doesn't
have a struggle saying once a week once
a day yeah so
this [ __ ]
have a word with this [ __ ] it's
a lot but yeah i mean
i understand guys a bit much dude
okay
hello
hello
[Music]